But you have to realize
that first, it's not enough
and you have to be
very much conscious
of not getting in love too much
with your idea,
especially, with your solution.
Chen Shmilo, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Good.
How are you, Michael?
Thank you so much for having me.
Thank you very much
for spending time here.
I know how busy you are
making a lot of impact.
And that's what I want
to talk about today, impact.
The impact that you're making right now
is in the context of 8200 impact.
And I can't wait to hear all about that.
But your journey is just
as fascinating as the work
that you're doing now.
And I know that you want to focus
a lot on the impact of this organization.
But I have to ask you
a little bit about yourself
and a little bit about your upbringing.
Start all the way back
to when you were leading
the course group
in your elementary school.
And then, zip forward all the way
to your public work
moving to the private sector.
Go ahead, Chen.
Yeah. That's sounds really
a  nice, fun fact. Right?
So, besides singing,
and it was only until Elementary School
you know, when my voice changed
then my plans have changed, too.
But I've always wanted
to be socially involved
and to lead social activism
wherever I was.
So, even studying in high school
when I was the head
of the student council,
then through initiating
a special project during
my military service at 8200 units,
and through my university experience
when I went to law school
in Haifa University
and I was the head
of the students board there,
it was always about using my skills,
knowledge, passion
to make things happen and change
whatever there is to change and fix.
So, this is basically who I am.
So, whenever I need to choose
my next step in my career path,
I'm always looking at the intersection
of what I know to do
and what I desire to do.
And I hope to find, you know,
the right meeting point,
the right intersection between
these two elements.
And this has led me
through pretty much diverse
positions till now.
And the reason is
being the managing director of 8200
impact acceleration program.
Right.
But before we get
to the 8200 impact program,
I have to talk a little bit about
this dissonance between
the public and private sector.
So, Chen, you're telling me
that the way that you grew up,
you are always looking for ways
to make an impact, right?
It's always been,
how can I find
a connection between
what I want to do
and what I can do
to make that impact.
You become a lawyer
and you go into the public
and NGO sector
trying to affect change
in your community.
So, tell me a little bit about
this motivation to affect change,
and sort of your realization
and transition from the public
to the private sector.
So, I think it started
during my internship.
And I did my legal internship
in one of the biggest law firms
here in Tel Aviv.
And was a really high quality
practice there, but I didn't really
feel connected to the mission.
And it was defending
and providing legal services
to really big corporations,
big private market entities.
And I couldn't feel
how we're changing the world
by providing them with legal services.
And there was even a specific case
where I understood the legal case,
it was pretty much obvious
what should be
the money that should be paid
to the other partner of the side
that we represented.
And yet we had to spend months and months
in district court in the north,
you know, hiring over
a very pretty much
small amount of money.
And I said, "Okay,
this is not my destiny."
And so, I was fortunate enough
after finishing my internship
and getting my lawyer license,
to be a legislative aide to the Knesset.
And I was like, you know,
big fortune to work
with former MK Dalia Itzik
in her last term
after she concluded her position
as the speaker of the Knesset
and was the head of the Kadima faction.
And even though it was quite
a short period of time, I learned a lot.
And working at the Knesset,
amending or proposing bills
to amend the law,
using my knowledge as a tourist
to pursue social changes,
I really liked it.
And so, there after the elections
back in 2013, I started to work
at the Israeli Medical Association
as their public policy director.
And this is where I had the chance
to promote public health issues
and represent the physicians
at the Knesset committees.
And this is,
you know, except of the best experience
that you gain working with leaders
of the physician world
and working with MKs with the government,
you also have the opportunities
to promote things that you believe in.
And that was the right place
for me back then.
Right.
But at some point, when I return
from the Humphrey Fellowship,
I was a food writer in the US,
spent almost a year
in Richmond, Virginia
focusing on public health management.
I came back,
I started being the CEO
of the non profit
in the health care system.
I managed to include
very important medicine,
preventive medicine
in the basic health
basket here in Israel, called PrEP.
Pre-exposure prophylaxis
that prevents HIV transmission.
But I also realized at the time that
there's something broken in the system.
It takes so much time.
You have to pull so many strings.
And I think, you know,
covid-19 pandemic now
is actually highlighted
what I started to realize
and feel even before
the pandemic started,
and that there has to be some kind
of a game changer in this world
so we have a more balanced economy,
more opportunities
for diverse population.
This is where I started to aim
at working in the private sector
and specifically just to pursue change.
So, in just a few sentences,
how do you summarize that realization,
that of the impact that you're able
to make in the private sector
versus the public sector?
Because I hear of a lot of people
that go from the private sector
to the public sector to effect change
because they're saying
the real power lies
in the decision makers,
in the government
and the NGOs, et cetera,
not in the private sector.
Yet Chen, you're saying I want to make
the biggest impact I can
so, I'm actually transitioning
from my work
in the public to the private.
Am I getting that right?
Yes, you are.
Well, the thing is that I think
the role of the government,
the role of the state actually
varies from one situation to another.
And sometimes,
the only thing the government needs to do
is not to intervene.
Sometimes it can be
the catalyst for helping
other organizations to make the change.
They can be a partner, sometimes.
They can be the regulator.
But I think and I truly believe
that the pandemic is highlighted
this notion, they are not as strong
as I used to think they are.
Public are the regulators.
So, the balance and the role is shifting.
And I don't think we can ignore them.
Absolutely not.
But I mean, look at everything.
Nobody could have done it better
than the private market
in collaboration and cooperation
with governments.
That should be
implemented in other fields to.
That makes perfect sense.
So, given that realization
and given that understanding
and your motivation,
talk to me a little bit about
what you're spending so much
of your time now,
making an impact through
the 8200 impact project.
What is the vision
and what's actually happening today?
Right.
So, we're actually affiliated
with the 8200 Alumni Association.
And it's part of our goal
to harness the human capital
of the alumni of the unit
for the sake of the economy and society,
we've created several exertion programs.
I run the 8200 impact
acceleration program,
which supports technological ventures
or what we call now,
impact tech startups.
Impact tech startups are different
by three criteria points of categories.
The first one is the intentionality test,
is whether they have initiated
the whole venture startup company
in order to make significant change
and to support significant social
or environmental problem.
How do you measure that?
How do you measure
intentionality amongst, you know,
early stage founders
that are just now beginning
their journey?
That's a wonderful question.
Usually by their statements.
Usually, by the way
they stick to their intention
throughout the process,
even though it is harder
to be in impact tech entrepreneur.
It is harder to find a business model,
it is harder to find investments.
In many cases, your beneficiaries
are not your clients
because your beneficiaries
are coming from disadvantaged communities
that cannot afford
paying for your product.
And then it becomes more complicated.
If they stick to the intention,
if they talk about what they do
in terms of not just making profit,
which is great,
and they have to make profit of course,
especially those who are aiming
at being a startup company,
but then talking about measuring
the social impact
and it has to be embedded
within the product.
Then if this test
is they're doing okay
with the first test of intentionality.
Right.
It is not a clear cut.
I mean, still black and white.
And sometimes people
are doing the social worship
just stating they care about impact,
about society or environment.
But at the bottom line, they're not.
So, you test along the way.
Right.
Okay, so that's the first test.
And walk me through
some of the other criteria
of how you are observing
these entrepreneurs.
The second one is whether they intend
and they have the ability to measure it.
So, we're looking at the measurable social
or environmental impact.
Usually at this stage,
we use this the SDG,
the Sustainable Development Goals
of the UN.
And it's not a perfect method.
But so far,
things are happening in this field.
So, we're using the SDGs mostly.
And the third one is, you know,
the financial revenue.
Whether they can be
a good fit for mainstream VCs,
of impact VCs, angel.
Whether they can come up
with a really good idea
and then product, the people
would want to invest in.
Right.
And combination of the three criteria,
it's pretty much complicated.
So, when you do accept people
into this cohort
or into this group and program,
what actually happens?
How do you actually help
these impact entrepreneurs
that you now call them
progressing to their, you know,
make it actually happen?
Yeah. So, it's a five-month program.
We usually select each year
between 10 to 12
entrepreneurs or ventures.
Some of them operated as a company.
Some are not at that stage.
We provide them with
a weekly day of workshops and lectures.
A very intensive mentorship program.
They have lead mentors,
professional mentors, office hours
and virtual board meetings.
You know, kind of tailor made
specific services plan
for each entrepreneur,
depending on the stage they're at,
depending on their current needs.
And I have to make sure
that I create for them the right space
to do amazing things.
Right.
Including connect and material support.
Sometimes even credits from
big corporation that can help them
do what they do
in a much faster pace.
And at the end,
we have a really
big event showcase event,
or annual demo day
in which they're being exposed
or investors are being exposed
to our portfolio companies.
Right.
So, tell me a little bit about the impact
that 8200 impact is making
and how do you measure that impact?
Are you a shareholder
or stakeholder in these companies?
What is sort of the relationship
that you have with the entrepreneurs
that are coming?
So, our model is a philanthropic one.
We don't charge anything.
We don't invest.
I mean, we don't get any equity.
We do have a board of partners
who are actually our sponsors
and they actually create the budgets
that we work with.
The way we measure our stuff,
that's a really good question, you know.
The program is now,
we're nearing the end
of the sixth batch.
So far, in the survey
that we conducted very much recently,
we have the figures of
the accumulated investment sum of money
of our companies
is a little bit more than $45 million.
And our startups have created
more than 100 jobs in Israel,
but not only in Israel.
Which is pretty much a common criteria
to measure an acceleration program.
We also asked them about
whether they measure their social impact
and then see,
you know, accordingly,
if we can also present
any progress with specific SDGs.
Right.
It's not that easy
for an early stage startup.
But we do see
some progressing relating to SDGs.
We're also adopting other methods
of management within
the startup company of diversity
and accessibility for people
with disability
and other criteria
that are more common
in impact tech ventures.
I think that makes perfect sense.
So Chen, I'd love to spend
the last few minutes
that we have talking
a little more broadly about impact
and some lessons
that you can provide
to young entrepreneurs,
whether they're in Tel Aviv
and can take part in
or in Israel and can take part
in this great program
or outside around the world.
What are some of the lessons
that you've learned along the way
of that make up
a successful impact venture?
Or at least a successful enough
to be able to take roots
and grow even passed
the first milestone
of the formation of it?
Wonderful question.
Well, first, being
an impact tech entrepreneur
is well, it starts with
being an entrepreneur.
And here I have no news.
You have to learn the whole
you know, the whole system.
Maybe people can read your book
that was recently published.
It starts with the notion
that you want to be an entrepreneur
you are courage enough.
Really.
Sometimes, maybe people will say
you're crazy enough
to start this amazing but
very very painful journey.
So, you have to be very much
passionate about it.
The second one that
you have to know
that making a positive impact
is not something
that has to do only with
being a purpose driven entrepreneur.
It is a whole system
where you also have to measure it.
Right.
The third thing I would say,
well, in many cases,
our entrepreneurs that we support,
have a very strong connection
between the product
and their personal life.
Interesting.
Sometimes,
a really interesting advantage.
Sometimes it could be very challenging.
So, for example, female entrepreneur,
that at some point
had a very negative experience
whether in terms of domestic violence
or feeling unsafe in public places
and she comes up
with a brilliant idea of creating
you know, an app that enhances
the feeling of being safe on the streets.
That could be an advantage.
I think that can really strengthen
your passion along the way.
But you have to realize
that first, it's not enough
and you have to be
very much conscious
of not getting in love too much
with your ideas,
especially with your solution.
I think that's, yeah,
I think that's a wonderful point
that you're making.
We actually had
a really brilliant guest.
I think she's episode 190 something,
Anita Kumari.
And she founded The Happiness Factor.
And she founded it as a result
of a very abusive relationship
that she had coming from India
into a marriage that was unsuccessful.
A very abusive marriage.
And she founded an organization
to help women gain confidence and support
for dealing with these things.
And so, I definitely see the value
and being very connected to the product
on an emotional level,
especially when
you are talking about impact.
The other thing that I want
to reiterate is you're mentioning
of both being intentional
but being measurable.
That you know, just because
you're making a social impact
and you're doing social good
often with impact,
it doesn't mean that you
should allow yourself
to not measure your process
and measure whether you're able
to continue making that impact.
Just like any regular venture
where you have to, you know,
you can sometimes measure sales
and measure your revenue
or your burn rate,
here and maybe you don't need
to measure sales,
but you do want to measure
whether the impact you're making
is growing because that is
the equivalent of sales
for regular venture.
You actually want to measure both.
And that what makes it more complicated.
So, you want to measure your sales,
you want to show fraction.
You want to show
that you're moving
the needle in terms of
the specific social challenge.
Wow. That makes a lot of sense.
Chen, I want to thank you
for being so generous with your time.
There's more
that I wanted to talk about,
but we don't have enough time for that.
So, we'll have to do another episode
in the future.
But before we leave,
I have to ask you
for the most important question,
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
It's the hardest question.
Of course.
I would say passionate.
I can't work with passionate people,
unless I'm passionate myself
about what I do.
I hope I'm genuine enough.
And then other two words,
maybe three phrases
and not three words,
social activist.
I truly believe, even being now
in this intersection of business
and making an impact,
I truly believe that
we are doing social activism
in an innovative way.
I love it.
Chen, thank you very, very much.
This is wonderful.
Continue making a positive impact
and continue helping others
make a positive impact.
And I can't wait to share this
with the world.
Thank you very much.
Toda raba.
Wonderful.
Thank you, Michael.